all right so this afternoon I thought
what it would be a good thing to do
would be to show you some uranium in
several of the videos previously you've
seen various forms of uranium and one of
them was just the metal but it always
appears black and it appears black
because it's got these oxide surfaces on
it but actually uranium just like lots
of other metals in the periodic table
should be a shiny silvery appearance
metal so I just thought I'd take this
opportunity just to we'll go in the lab
and we'll clean some up and I'll show
you some actual naked uranium if you
like because it's really very pretty to
look up
my colleague and co-presenter on these
videos steve little has got a big grant
to study the chemistry of uranium
chemical research is really quite
expensive you have to pay for the
chemicals the equipment and the salaries
of the people that do it and steve has
been very fortunate to get a grant from
the European Research Council which
gives grants to young researchers all
over Europe so we're very proud of him
and more excitingly
is going to lead to lots of new
chemistry of uranium right so what we've
got here is a beaker which contains some
uranium turnings and as you can see they
look kind of dark in color normally that
they look really black onto the oil but
as we've got them out and we've thinned
them out a bit you can already start to
see shiny edges on them because actually
that's the true colour of uranium it was
originally a block of uranium and it was
machined on a lathe which has just
turned it all out as little turnings
because that's achieves you for us to
handle because it's got a bigger surface
area and uranium as a metal is really
very hard so you can't just saw an edge
off it because you'd actually blunt the
saw before you would actually get a bit
chopped off so you have to use really
hard drill bits to get the sare uranium
turned off now it looks still looks
fairly dark and that's because it's got
this oxide layer on it which is
passivated it over time because uranium
is quite a hard metal so it allowed to
be bonded to hard elements like oxygen
we're going to get rid of this oil and
wash it a few times just to make sure
it's free of that and then we're going
to treat it with concentrated nitric
acid and the nitric acid attacks the
oxide layer and pulls all the oxygens
off and just leaves with a nice
uranium underneath when it does that it
gives off clouds of no.2 which is
obvious so you start to see that coming
off in the solution there darkening and
then what you should see after we've
washed it a few times is the nice shiny
matte surface and that was actually
there all the time underneath I think it
is about million euros so it's really
quite a large sum of money that's one
and a half million dollars so it's a lot
of money but it's over five years and
will pay for a good team for him to do
his research with and so I think we can
look forward to a lot more new compounds
on YouTube like all our uranium in the
lab this is depleted which means that
all essentially all of the radioactive
content component has been removed so
this is essentially non radioactive its
toxic as a heavy metal would be like
lead but it's no worse than LED really
I'm just weighing it now because part of
the rules that govern the fact that
allowed to use this stuff is that we
have to keep an accurate measure of how
much we've used every time okay so now
we've got these turnings they're free of
the oil and we're going to treat them
with concentrated nitric acid which is
going to clean them up this is a very
strong acid so you have to handle it
quite carefully
chemically right now the HNO 3 which is
the nitric acid that's reacting with
what on the surface is you oh and we
don't know how many oxygens there are as
was excavated again and it's going to
react to make water no.2 so that hno3 is
going to fall apart and reorganize and
as you can see that our solutions
starting to get a little bit of color to
it and that's because the cognero is
attacking this oxide layer and it's
generating little bits of no.2 which is
going off and it's generating water at
the same time so it's got this sort of
yellow color - already so it's not a
large amount of no.2 being given off but
it's a little bit if you get really
reactive very small uranium turnings
sometimes you get like clouds of no.2
coming off so that the trick with this
is to leave it just long enough that you
get rid of all the black oxide layer but
not too long that you start eating away
at the actual nice shiny metal as well
and end up with nothing left so you just
have to keep an eye on it but all the
time you can see the solutions getting
darker and darker and that's because
there's no.2 component coming off
right and then we're going to tip this
out and Pat them dry so there you go
some naked geranium I went to the I that
would look like just any other metal and
tall intense purposes because the
radioactive component is gone that's all
it is it's just another metal in the
periodic table only it's the boovie man
well if I just left that in that
weighing boat slowly but surely the the
surface layer of the uranium would start
to react with oxygen in the air and
you'd start to darken again and you'll
get this on thick oxide layer building
up again so we have to put it in an
ampule and get it away from air and then
it will stay intact the future of that
uranium there is that we will react it
with iodine and turn it into uranium
triiodide and that's one of our starting
to us to make these interesting
compounds because you can exchange the
halides for other groups which make it
much more soluble and you can get them
in the solution and then crystallize
them out and make throwing ice crystals
and compounds